you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
just days away from the global climate
summit in glasgow the chancellor gives
air travel a boost with a cut to air
passenger duty
and the disappointment of the lack of
green measures in the budget too is the
prime minister says the cop is in the
balance
meanwhile southern italy and sicily
recover from a rare cyclonic storm but
forecasts suggest more severe weather
ahead
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
climate campaigners are questioning the
chancellor's decision to cut air
passenger duty on domestic flights in
today's budget of course that
announcement comes just days before the
uk hosts the annual global climate
summit in glasgow
and while an increase in duty on
long-haul flights might cancel out
higher emissions from more domestic air
travel critics say giving travelers high
carbon options simply won't help
accelerate a reduction in overall
emissions but our chief political
correspondent john craig joins us now
from westminster hello to john now what
message does this tax cut send to the
public about air travel
well what the government is arguing is
of course that uh long-haul flights uh
caused more damage than short-haul
flights now in his budget speech when he
made his announcement about cutting air
passenger duty for domestic flights he
said that people pay more for return
flights within the four nations of the
uk than they do from flying from abroad
and he says he's going to bring this in
from april 2023 so it's not yet
he says um it'll help the cost of living
uh nine million passengers see their
duty cut by half he'll say it'll bring
people together across the uk uh he also
said it was a boost for regional
airports like aberdeen belfast inverness
southampton he said
what the government has also said is
that international travel accounts for
eight percent of emissions whereas
domestic flights only count for one
percent uh and so that's how they're
justifying it i have to say during the
budget debate the uh snp leader uh ian
blackford led the assault on this move
uh he said it was a disgrace he said as
cop 26 kicks off this weekend what on
earth are we doing we're saying to the
rest of the world the prime minister has
spoken today about 4.5 degrees so a lot
of criticism of this also from green
groups as well so it's a very
controversial move just before the cop
summit
yeah john also the chancellor of course
being criticized for this lack of a
green focus in his budget just days from
cop as you say is this a strategy or a
sign that things aren't being taken
seriously
well that's what critics say critics are
saying it's a missed opportunity now
among the critics uh later in that
debate where the former prime minister
theresa may
she criticized the lack of green
skills helpful green skills in the
economy she said she talked about the
the green industrial revolution isn't
just about providing support for
business it's about the green skills of
the future now earlier
standing in for uh sir kia starmer
who tested positive for uh kovid minutes
before prime minister's questions ed
miliband the shadow business secretary
former labour leader one of the
government's biggest critics on cop and
the environment laid into boris johnson
over the whole preparations for cop
now a couple of days ago when he was
talking to some children the prime
minister said success for cop was touch
and go this was what the prime minister
said in response to mr miliband
cop 26 is both
unbelievably important for our planet
but also very difficult and it's in the
balance we've moved from only 30 percent
of the global economy uh committed to a
net zero by the middle of the century to
now 80 and uh every day as i talk to
international leaders we hear further
commitments to make those solid
commitments that the world will need
whether it is enough mr speaker i'm
afraid it is too early to say
well critics will say it's a bit late
now because of course it's only a few
days till cop starts at the weekend
tomorrow on day two of the budget debate
in the house of commons it's
quasi-cuateng the business and energy
secretary who is opening the debate and
mr miliband will again be no doubt on
the attack uh we can expect to hear a
lot more criticism of the uh uh move on
passenger duty air flight to flight tax
being cut for domestic uh uh uh
passengers and of course uh uh another
lack of a green strategy and we'll and
of course it'll probably be the last
opportunity for mps to debate cop before
it actually gets underway
so prime minister said earlier in the
week touch and go today saying too early
to say is it all about managing
expectations cynics will no doubt claim
it is uh but on the other hand it could
be that the prime minister is worried
that there are some setbacks on the way
and it may not be the success that the
government is hoping for
john an important few weeks ahead of us
thanks very much indeed
now parts of southern italy and sicily
are braced for more severe weather after
a rare cyclonic storm hit the region
at least two people were killed when
torrential rain caused widespread
flooding around the city of catania the
italian met office says the storm is
expected to peak tomorrow and friday
when gale force winds will create a
coastal storm sky's emma birchley
reports
wading waist high through the murky gush
of flood water a passerby leads a man to
safety from his abandoned car
the unremitting rain has turned streets
like this one in the sicilian city of
catania into rivers as residents were
urged not to risk leaving their homes
a rare cyclonic storm has caused the
downpours but it didn't stop some
venturing out despite the warnings for
many in the region the clear-up has
already begun belongings piled high away
from the muck left behind
carmella mondio described what had
happened as a catastrophe
plenty of water entered my house in
these two days inside the drawers on the
floor she said
there is still mud because we haven't
managed to clean it
it's not the first time samantha
seminara has been through this and it's
hard to cope with
we are trying to save as much as we can
she said
nobody gave us anything here everything
comes from my sacrifices and the
sacrifices of my husband
further south in scordia rescuers have
been searching for the wife of a 67 year
old man already found dead in an orange
grove after their car was swept more
than a mile in two meters of water
another man who was 53 also drowned
elsewhere in flood waters after
reportedly getting out of his car
the sicilian farmers association says
nearly a foot of rain fell on the island
in just a few hours on sunday and
there's no let up in sight
with red warnings for further rain and
thunderstorms continuing into thursday
emma birchley sky news
well let's take a look at some of
today's other climate news and insulate
britain says it will continue to disrupt
traffic despite court injunctions
banning the group from blocking key
roads across england dozens of
protesters were arrested this morning
after they blocked two major roads into
london once again during rush hour the
group is calling on the government to
insulate millions of homes to reduce
emissions
with just days to go before cop 26 mps
have taken part in a debate at
westminster hall on climate education
they discussed how students could be
taught about the climate crisis and
learn the skills that are needed for
green jobs labour mp nadia whittam who
tabled the debate called it the first
step towards making climate education a
legal requirement across the curriculum
and it's emerged that the uk has
invested in a fossil fuel project in
mozambique whose emissions were assessed
against a target of two degrees of
global warming rather than the
internationally recognized one and a
half degrees
the project involves a liquefied natural
gas plant in the cabo delgado province
which campaigners say contradicts the
uk's commitment to cut emissions the
news comes of course the week before the
uk hosts the cop 26 climate talks the
government has made the aim of the talks
to keep the 1.5 degree ambition alive
and you can find the full story on the
sky news website
now china has warned that shifting its
energy mix from coal to renewables will
be challenging and cannot be
accomplished overnight it comes a day
after its government released a new
action plan which details how it will
meet its target of peaking carbon
emissions by 2030. sky's tom cheshire
has the latest from beijing
i think a lot of people were hoping for
something big from china ahead of cop 26
perhaps new pledges but we certainly
haven't had that instead we've had a lot
more detail on the pledges announced
last year by president xi jinping to be
carbon neutral by 2060 and to peak
emissions by 2030 but especially on coal
which china still burns a tremendous
amount of and is still adding a lot of
coal power a lot of people have been
disappointed i asked people from the
environment ministry at a press
conference today about that here's what
they had to say
as a developing country china is
currently facing the arduous tasks of
developing the economy improving
people's livelihood
eradicating poverty and maintaining
national security there are still many
practical difficulties and challenges in
adjusting the energy structure which
cannot be accomplished overnight
so what you saw there was all the
obstacles for china actually trying to
cut down coal and that will be deeply
worrying ahead of cop the other thing
that was stressed in that press
conference was how is the responsibility
of developed wealthy nations to lead the
way to drastically reduce their
emissions on climate change and not for
developing nations china classes itself
as a developing nations so it's clearly
saying that for breakthroughs to happen
at cop it's going to happen to come from
the western countries and that again
puts a dampener on what we can expect
this is the mood music from beijing
ahead of cop 26 ahead of glasgow and
that mood is pretty dark right now
now do you stay with us because coming
up after the break i'll be joined by
greenpeace uk's head of climate clait
blagojevich and organic farmer and
deputy president of the national farmers
union stuart roberts there they are
standing by we'll be discussing whether
the chancellor has budgeted for climate
change and how to inspire people to make
friendly choices that's after this short
break
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change
correspondent the uk is a world leader
in wind power
[Music]
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm conference for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is i'm not here to
apologize i'm here to fight for the next
step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these this sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of action going on
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
this is what makes the job
so fantastic
so
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
there'll
stuff
a mild windy start with rain from
cornwall up into southern scotland and
heavy showers to the west northern
england will stay wet through the
morning and wales in southwest england
will turn wet but southern scotland will
largely dry up elsewhere it'll be mostly
fine but the north-western scotland can
expect heavy showers it'll stay very
mild scotland will see showers clearing
later there'll be little change
elsewhere the unsettled conditions mean
air pollution levels should remain low
with levels between 1 and 3 on the daily
air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
and welcome back to the daily climate
show on sky news and we're getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day with greenpeace uk's
head of climate kate blagojevich and
organic farmer and deputy president of
the national farmers union stuart
roberts a very warm welcome to you both
thank you for joining us
well perhaps surprisingly considering
the global climate change summit
starting in glasgow in just a few days
time today's budget was not dominated by
spending on climate the government did
of course announce a whole raft of new
climate measures including its net zero
strategy just last week so was it
inevitable given the post-covert
environment that green measures would be
overshadowed in today's budget kate to
you first your reaction to that
i think that the climate emergency
should have been at the heart of this
autumn budget uh obviously there were a
raft of policies announced last week but
without the money to back up those
policies they're just words on paper and
that doesn't lead to any action at all
and that means that the climate targets
that those policies
are supposed to be hitting just simply
aren't going to be reached without the
money to back them up it felt very much
like richie sunak was much more
interested in investing in prosecco than
he was the planet and stuart your
thoughts after today's budget of course
a lot of criticism at the lack of green
spending of course just days ahead of
cop
as the host nation what did you make of
that was that odd to you the optics of
that perhaps
i think one of the things for me is an
and kate touched on this you you can't
look at the budget in isolation i think
you've got to look at it alongside
the the net zero strategy
and look there are still some big
funding gaps there that need to be
filled as kate said but i also look at
it through the lens of of my sector my
industry there were some things in the
budget so for example the announcement
about business rate investment relief
for on-site renewables or green
technologies that will definitely help
our sector get towards net zero there is
still a lot more to be done
but it wasn't all disappointment but
there are still those funding gaps
missing
and a strategy without funding isn't uh
isn't a strategy we've got to have the
funding that goes with it as well
yeah kate see you next uh as stuart
referenced there you know the government
has allocated 30 billion pounds to
create new green industries of the
future since march as the chancellor
referenced once again today do you think
that budget day is simply far too
complex
a day far too complex in terms of its
level of announcements in public
spending to make those sorts of big
green announcements
i think no because i do think that the
green announcement should have been very
clear from the outset the moment that he
stood up he should have been talking
about the climate crisis we're days away
from cop we can see that extreme weather
events are happening today they're
happening every single day all around
the world we're hearing from un
scientists
with new reports every single day saying
how
we the uk but also globally are not
hitting the climate targets that we
should be in order to try and keep
temperature rises to 1.5 the chancellor
and this government do need to be doing
much more than making announcements and
saying targets they need to be
allocating the money to back them up
and stuart just lastly on this issue uh
what do you make of the decision to cut
air passenger duty by 50 on domestic
flights of course fuel duties are almost
at a record high at the moment uh
low-income families are really
struggling
was this a surprise to you
i'm trying to say it was a surprise as
someone who actually took a decision a
few years ago not to take domestic
flights precisely for uh the
environmental reasons um i was very
surprised by that one and uh yeah that
came a bit left field i thought
okay
on to our next issue now and of course
it's a rare day when we don't mention a
climate report on this show from a big
international institution more often
than not they're telling policy makers
that targets simply aren't enough that
not enough is being spent and they were
heading for climate catastrophe so is
the message getting through to people
how difficult is it for people to work
out how they can personally help on
climate
kate
to you first you've been with greenpeace
since 2014 have you sensed a change in
the public mood
i have yes i think that over the last
few years we've seen that public the
public are much more interested in
climate change they're much more
concerned about climate change and
that's true i think even now
uh while we're in the middle of a
pandemic where some people might said
actually climate change is going to go
on a back burner for a lot of people
actually what's happening is that the
climate emergency and tackling it is
still one of the top voting issues for
people we've seen loads of polling
coming out this year basically all
saying that the majority of people want
the government to be taking much more
climate action they want to be spending
a lot more money to make sure that the
crisis is taken seriously and that the
government actually acts like we're in a
climate crisis which we are as well as
obviously
dealing with the pandemic and
understanding that the two can actually
go hand in hand and that we should be
really making sure that we're we've got
a green recovery coming out of the
covert pandemic
that's what people are really interested
in now
yeah very interesting and stewart your
thoughts on that typically people
wouldn't care about global issues in the
middle of a recession are you sensing a
change too in terms of what people care
about and what you're hearing within the
farming industry and agriculture
i i absolutely am i think people see
this as a as an opportunity to to take
stock to change things i think as kate
says this green recovery point if i look
at the farming industry itself over the
last three four five years as we've been
starting to talk about net zero as an
industry farmers are really feeling
empowered they feel as though they can
be part of that solution and that
empowerment i think is really important
but it's also important i think at every
life stage so one of the most exciting
things we've been doing is actually
doing some stem projects in classrooms
with kids
and actually getting them to see where
agriculture
butts up against and can be a solution
to climate change getting youngsters
involved getting everyone involved and
ultimately for me it's about empowering
every single one of us as an individual
to be part of that solution
and actually it's just part of our
everyday life doing something every day
to do our bit for the planet
and kate there's far more information
and dialogue now around about climate
change but many people have quite a high
proportion of people find it quite
confusing what they're reading on social
media of course mp's debating today
educating students on climate issues but
do you think they should be focusing on
other generations as well
i think honestly i do think that climate
information needs to be very clear very
accessible and it's what i spend quite a
lot of my time thinking about um so that
we can inspire everybody to get involved
and to do their bit whether that's
signing petitions whether that's getting
involved in local air pollution
campaigns whether that's writing to
their mps obviously we've seen it the
future generation of school strikers
have been hugely inspiring in terms of
what they've been doing and the protests
that they've been holding
so i think that there is a huge amount
of work to be done still to make sure
that the information is getting out
there so that people can really
understand it and know what needs to be
done
really appreciate your thoughts today
kate blagojevich and stuart thank you
very much indeed
well that's everything from us for today
joining me on tomorrow's show is climate
scientist ella gilbert and international
ambassador of the conservative
environment network stanley johnson but
do stay tuned because coming up next of
course more on the budget the chancellor
promising billions but has he delivered
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]